so great you made it halfway this is the
third tutorial now to make your shots
more filmic
so this is the shot we'll be working on
today
this is the before this is after again
this is super underexposed but
uh this is how i want it to be so i'm
not trying to
get all the details in the shadows
because i'm not interested to see
what's there okay i'm only interested to
see his
silhouette and the light right here
through the window okay
so let's press f7 on windows to make a
new variant
as always bring the sharpening all the
way down because we don't need
all that detail luminance down
single pixel up you don't always have to
do this okay
but since the shot uh is going to be a
little bit noisy
because it's a shot at iso 2500
and i'm gonna bring a little bit i'm
gonna i'm gonna force
the details in the shadow a little bit
i'm gonna bring them back
so since we are recovering a lot of
information in the shadows
it's gonna be a little bit noisy okay so
as we can see
i could have i could have exposed this a
little bit better
yeah but that's not a problem
okay so first things first brightness
all the way up i
only need to see a line the line of his
face i'm not trying to
bring up all the details you know like
right there
because i'm not interested in that
okay so i brought the brightness all the
way up shadows
a little bit up exposure a little bit up
cool
then crush the whites just a little bit
cool or a little bit more it depends how
you like it
good maybe the shadow is just a little
bit more like that like so
cool okay okay
good so if you look here
if you zoom in you can see there is a
lot
a lot of noise so
maybe maybe add a little bit more
luminance
if we if we bring down
the single pixel we can see there are a
lot of white dots
and some hot pixels
but just bring it all the way up and
it's cool no problem
good so what we're trying to do here
is make all the yellows more
like a pinkish vibrant look
and the blues somewhat green like cyan
green whatever and these are
violets at the moment okay so that that
being said
what you could do just go to the color
editor and in this last
uh square just go to the hue and do this
okay
but not all the way up just a little bit
cool
like so add more green in the highlights
cool go
into the let's check it's right here in
the blue
maybe a little bit in right there in the
magenta
okay so the blue ones right there
saturation
not all the way up but you know okay
cool
i'll add a little bit more green oh no
no
okay i didn't want to do that go back to
the violet
you can't really see that because it's
right there see it's right that one that
part so it's super super small
but it's important to just like
yeah i'll bring the greens a little bit
down
because i want to get the blue uh the
violet or whatever this patch is
to be a little bit more to the green
side cool
something like that and now let's go
into the
into the now let's go into the yellow
and uh shift a little bit to
red like
so cool
should we add more color into the
shadows
not that we really want to but something
like that
[Music]
okay
cool there you go
okay so that's it there you have it this
is the before
this is after super simple super easy
super simple and fast so i hope you
enjoyed this tutorial
and i hope to see you in the next one
thanks goodbye